SCP-682 VS An Industrial-Grade Blender Followed
by Strong Centrifuge.
Could this, the most hardcore of industrial
kitchen equipment, finally take down the Hard
to Destroy Reptile?
A 682 tissue sample was reduced into a fine
slurry by the blender and then placed into
the centrifuge, which slowly increased to
a truly insane number of rotations per minute.
And…
The sample exploded, severely injuring twelve
members of personnel and almost killing Dr.
Carlson, one of the lead researchers on the
project.
It turned out that SCP-682’s flesh contains
anti-matter, hence the violent chemical reaction
that transpired.
Naturally, further testing of this matter
was forbidden by the O5 Council, to reduce
the number of unnecessary explosions occurring
on site.
I guess we’ll never truly know the outcome
on this one huh?